y el anuncio de esta reunión el próximo
martes en viena abre una ventana de
esperanza sobre un posible regreso de
eeuu al acuerdo nuclear del cual se
retiró el presidente de donald trump en
el 2018 si bien en las últimas horas el
ministro de exteriores iraní mohammad
javad sheriff en un trino dijo que esto
no serán conversaciones directas con
washington y la prensa iraní fue incluso
más allá y dijo que ni siquiera eran
conversaciones indirectas la realidad es
mucho más compleja que ésta esta reunión
de los cinco países firmantes de ese
acuerdo que quedan ahí como son alemania
reino unido francia china y rusia- con
los representantes de teherán no tiene
otro objetivo que buscar cómo eeuu puede
volver a este acuerdo nuclear y cómo
levantar las sanciones económicas que es
lo que pide irán ya se conoce que
washington enviará delegados a los
pasillos de esta reunión y lo que dicen
los analistas es cómo buscar un
cronograma conjunto en el cual eeuu
poder ir levantando las sanciones e irán
pueda ir volviendo a cumplir esos
compromisos que hay
retrocediendo desde que trump se
retirará en el 2018 sin embargo el
discurso oficial de irán es que eeuu
tiene que levantar totalmente las
sanciones económicas para ellos cumplir
lo pactado para washington pide lo
contrario así que tendrán que encontrar
un punto común y ahí es donde están las
dificultades para volver a este acuerdo
nuclear